hi welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion
throughout history few individuals have
wielded the power to shape and shake the
world as profoundly as J Robert
Oppenheimer a man of remarkable
intellect and deep-seated conflicts
oppenheimer's life dance precariously
between the shadows of morality and the
blinding light of scientific progress
renowned as the father of the atomic
bomb he was the driving force behind the
Manhattan Project the project
responsible for delivering the most
devastating weapon the world had ever
seen his story however is not one of
unmitigated Glory it's a tale of
ambition anguish genius guilt success
and Scandal was he a hero who helped end
a bloody world war or just a villain who
Unleashed Untold destruction the answer
like Oppenheimer himself is complex and
intriguing is a man of many stories so
get comfortable as we uncover The Life
and Legacy of Robert Oppenheimer
[Music]
TV
foreign
[Music]
on April 22nd 1904 in New York City to
wealthy German Jewish immigrants Julius
Robert Oppenheimer was a prodigy in the
truest sense he showed a profound knack
for Science and literature at a young
age
his father ran a business importing
textiles and made a lot of money doing
it to give you an idea of how rich his
family was their New York Penthouse had
paintings of Van Gogh and Picasso on the
wall
the issue with Robert was that he grew
up spoiled everything he wanted his
parents would get for him and this
caused emotional problems later in life
in school Robert was extremely bright
but boastful and he was bullied as a
result
at summer camp other boys would strip
him of his clothes and make him sleep in
an ice house overnight
Oppenheimer withdrew inwards putting his
mind towards physics he once told his
brother quote I need physics more than I
need friends end quote
he was gifted however and raced through
school absorbing material at a
frightening Pace he graduated at age 17.
after a brief time at Harvard he would
attend Cambridge University
being in a different country the young
student was isolated and lonely his
family wasn't there to spoil him anymore
around this time Robert had broken up
with his long-term girlfriend and was
having bitter arguments with his mother
at this point he fell into a depressed
state the shy young man grew mentally
unstable and the cracks began to show
one of his few friends Francis Ferguson
came to visit Ferguson would mention to
Oppenheimer that he was about to get
engaged
upon hearing the news Oppenheimer
snapped how was his friend doing so much
better than he was the skinny rich kid
launched on Ferguson knocking him to the
ground and attempting to choke him in a
fit of unhinged rage
Ferguson was twice the size of
Oppenheimer so he flicked him off and
told him to grow up though this was just
a warning sign of things to come
[Music]
now Oppenheimer had a tutor named
Patrick blackett blackett wanted
Oppenheimer to do Hands-On lab work
which he hated
Oppenheimer developed a seething hatred
for blackett
things would come to a head in 1926 when
Oppenheimer injected an apple with
poison and placed it on blackett's desk
he then would leave the room and went on
vacation
thankfully Patrick never ate the apple
but while on vacation Oppenheimer broke
down and confessed his crime to his
friends
news got back to Cambridge University
and the administrators decided to press
charges for attempted murder
that would have probably been the end of
Oppenheimer except his Rich father
managed to talk his son out of the
situation all that he got was probation
and an order to seek a counselor
[Music]
things would improve however when he
moved to guten Gooden University in 1926
here he would come into contact with the
legendary Max born who himself had
recently coined the term quantum
mechanics
for context at the time born would
Mentor Verna Heisenberg of the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle and
Enrico Fermi of the Fermi Paradox while
also under the mentorship of Max born
Oppenheimer excelled in theoretical
physics he had found his calling and the
dissatisfaction in academics lifted and
his State of Mind vastly improved
Oppenheimer graduated at age 23 with a
PhD in physics in just two years he had
published over a dozen papers
after his time in Germany Robert became
a professor at Cal Berkeley
Robert had a tendency to LEAP from topic
to topic and it really frustrated his
colleagues he'd randomly dropped physics
for months to read philosophy or learn
the Sanskrit language
he also threw himself into left-wing
politics even throwing fundraisers to
Communists in the Spanish Civil War
these associations with Communist party
members would later significantly impact
his life and career
one of his friends Freeman Dyson would
later recall Oppenheimer just had the
inability to sit still and just see
things through but even with these
traits Oppenheimer became somewhat of an
academic icon because of his brilliant
mind but despite personal struggles
oppenheimer's stature in the scientific
Community continued to rise in 1941 he
was invited to join the Manhattan
Project the U.S government's Ultra
secret program to develop an atomic bomb
accepting this role would forever change
the course of his life and indeed the
course of history
[Music]
the Genesis of nuclear warfare began to
take shape in the United States with a
singular pivotal letter penned by
physicist Leo slislet and endorsed by
none other than Albert Einstein the
letter dispatched to President Franklin
D Roosevelt in August of 1939 described
how an atomic bomb would theoretically
be possible within the correspondence
there was also a dire warning Germany
had already begun to stockpile sources
of uranium from Czechoslovakia this
suggested that the Nazis were on a path
to an atomic bomb of their own the
gravity of this communication coupled
with the escalation of World War II
called for an Urgent Response from the
United States and in 1942 the Manhattan
Project was formed this was a colossal
scientific and Military collaboration
Endeavor to forge a weapon of
unimaginable power a deterrent so
formidable that it would end the war and
discourage future conflicts Central to
this historic mission was the
appointment of J Robert Oppenheimer it
was an unparalleled leadership role
marking the beginnings of his legacy
Oppenheimer seemed an unconventional
choice for the Project Director he was a
theoretical physicist not an engineer
and to add to this his political
associations raised some eyebrows among
security agencies regardless General
Leslie gross the military head of the
project saw in Oppenheimer the rare
combination of brilliant intellect
Charisma and administrative expertise
as a leader his quick mind proved to be
a huge asset with his intellect he could
Pierce through all the noise and
immediately get to the heart of a
problem without this unique mindset the
atomic bomb may have never come to be
oppenheimer's first major challenge was
the establishment of the secret
laboratory where the bomb would be
designed and constructed he chose the
isolated location of Los Alamos New
Mexico he envisioned it as a hub of
scientific innovation it would be in
these remote surroundings that
Oppenheimer transformed from an academic
into a leader
in a way the fate of the entire world
was in his hands
Oppenheimer would rise to the challenge
and managed to show remarkable
leadership skills he bridged gaps
between scientists of different
disciplines managed Egos and defused
conflicts despite the intense pressure
he maintained a focus on scientific
Community even creating a school for the
children of his team and ensuring the
overall welfare of those under his
charge while the technical challenges of
the Manhattan Project were formidable
oppenheimer's role extended beyond the
scientific realm he managed to navigate
the political intricacies of a higher
Stakes government-funded Endeavor he
also had to Grapple with the ethical
implications of his work implications
that carried the heaviest of burdens
but ethics was not the only challenge
developing the atomic bomb required
overcoming two primary technical
challenges one was obtaining enough
material capable of sustaining a nuclear
fission chain reaction and the second
was engineering a device that could
trigger those chain reactions
uranium-235 and naturally occurring but
scarce isotope and plutonium t39 a
synthetic element were identified as
suitable materials the reason for the
choice of these elements was due to
their ability to start a sustained or
runaway chain reaction when hit with a
neutron particle a feat that was thought
to be impossible just two decades
earlier
a single particle starts the reaction
splitting the uranium atom here now is
the release of energy as heat and blast
but here here are free neutrons driven
out with tremendous speed and provided
there is sufficient u-235 present what
science calls a critical mass those
neutrons bombard other uranium atoms
causing them to split and split still
others the result a chain reaction over
a million billion billion atoms
exploding within two seconds but
extracting uranium-235 from the much
more prevalent uranium-238 or producing
plutonium-239 in a nuclear reactor was a
colossal task a task that required
unprecedented industrial efforts so the
engineers set to work designing testing
and ultimately creating a mechanism that
rapidly collected masses of these
materials next was overcoming the
destination issues it was a difficult
challenge but the engineers and
scientists eventually figured it out
these technical Feats represented the
Apex of scientific and Engineering
Innovation at the time
it was July 16 1945 and all was still in
the new Mexican desert
suddenly an explosion ripped through the
calm air and a terrifyingly loud roar
followed
the first atomic bomb codenamed the
gadget had just been successfully
detonated at the Trinity test site the
mushroom cloud Rose 12 kilometers in
altitude and the Shockwave blast could
be felt over 160 kilometers away
[Music]
as the mushroom cloud billowed into the
sky Oppenheimer reportedly quoted a line
from the Hindu scripture bhagavad-gita
he said quote now I am become death the
destroyer of worlds
this sentiment captured the ore Terror
and sorrow that came from the creation
of complete devastation
In This Moment the global population was
unknowingly ushered into the atomic age
the US government had actually planned
to cover up the event the sound and
sight of which would be hard to
completely ignore a writer for the New
York Times William Lawrence was drafted
into the Manhattan Project just for this
cover-up he had multiple statements
written one of which involved The
Accidental deaths of hundreds ultimately
he would write that the explosion and
heat wave was caused by a quote remotely
located ammunition magazine containing a
considerable amount of high explosives
and pyrotechnics end quote the public
was none the wiser
the ultimate culmination of the
Manhattan Project's effort was the
creation of two types of atomic bombs
little boy a uranium 235 weapon and fat
man a plutonium 239 weapon the decision
to deploy these newly developed Atomic
weapons was not taken lightly in
mid-1945 World War II was grinding into
its sixth year and despite Germany's
surrender in May Japan continued to
resist the Pacific War had taken a heavy
toll and the brutal island-topping
campaigns had shown that Japan was
willing to fight to the last man
an invasion of Mainland Japan codenamed
operation downfall was predicted to
result in hundreds of thousands if not
millions of Allied casualties meanwhile
intelligence had discovered something
chilling reports emerged that the
Japanese Army had developed a biological
weapons program Unit 731 the facilities
conducted horrific experiments on human
subjects and worst of all for the United
States in about one month they were
preparing a biological attack on the
American West Coast the payload would
contain fleas carrying the Bubonic
plague one of the most dangerous
diseases in world history these
Revelations added an extra layer of
urgency and danger
just as the war was reaching its peak in
April of 1945 President Roosevelt would
die and it was President Harry S Truman
who would take over quickly he was
briefed about the Manhattan Project and
the unprecedented destructive power of
the atomic bombs Truman and his advisors
were faced with a devastating Choice use
the atomic bomb and potentially end the
war swiftly but at a terrible
humanitarian cost or proceed with the
land Invasion which would likely result
in as many if not more horrifying
casualties
ultimately as we all know the decision
was made to drop the atomic bombs it was
August 6 1945 and little boy was dropped
on Hiroshima
surrender or face complete destruction
the ultimatum was ignored
at 10 58 the morning of August 9th
Japanese time the second Atomic Palm was
exploded over the industrial Seaport
city of Nagasaki
and three days later fat man was dropped
on Nagasaki both cities were completely
devastated and the human toll was
catastrophic
when little boy detonated approximately
600 meters above Hiroshima it Unleashed
a blast equivalent to about 15 000 tons
of TNT instantly obliterating 1300
hectares of City Center an estimated 70
000 people were killed instantly the
ensuing Firestorm consumed the city
causing a death toll estimated at 140
000 by the end of 1945. Nagasaki
suffered a similar Fate on August 9th
when fat man was detonated though the
bomb was more powerful its damage was
less extensive due to the city's hilly
geography nonetheless an estimated 40
000 people died instantly the adventure
death toll Rose to approximately 70 000
by the end of the year in both cities
many who initially survived would suffer
from severe burns injuries from the
blast and radiation sickness there was
Untold suffering and death in the
following weeks months and years
and just a point to note even though the
Japanese military and government were
guilty of horrific war crimes the
Japanese civilian population was
innocent
within weeks Japan surrendered bringing
an end to World War II
I deem this reply a full acceptance of
the pups Dam decoration
which specifies the unconditional
surrender of Japan
in the reply there is no qualification
[Music]
[Applause]
the use of atomic bombs marked a
devastating new chapter in Warfare
exposing Humanity for the first time to
the potential of complete
self-destruction throughout this period
Oppenheimer found himself in the midst
of an escalating debate within the
scientific community and the military
hierarchy his role however was largely
advisory the ultimate decision to drop
the bombs was in the hands of the
political and military leaders still he
was deeply affected by the loss of life
and the destruction caused by the
weapons he had helped create
foreign
in the aftermath of World War II
Oppenheimer became a symbol of the new
atomic age his name would be forever
intertwined with the Manhattan Project
and the dawn of nuclear weapons the most
destructive weapon in human history but
he was also a man deeply conflicted
about the consequences of his work
post-war Oppenheimer ascended to a
position of significant influence in
shaping America's nuclear policy in 1947
he was appointed as the chairman of the
general advisory committee of the newly
established atomic energy commission
here he would become a powerful advocate
for the international control of nuclear
power to avert a global arms race in his
role as the chairman of the general
advisory committee of the atomic energy
commission Oppenheimer became
increasingly vocal about his concerns
regarding the escalation of nuclear
weapons development
he was particularly opposed to the
development of the hydrogen bomb he
viewed it as a weapon of genocidal
proportions his position put him at
direct odds with influential figures of
the American Military and government one
of whom was Lewis Strauss chairman of
the atomic energy commission and Edward
Teller often referred to as the father
of the hydrogen bomb
they viewed oppenheimer's stance as a
hindrance to America's strategic
interests during the Cold War
and things would only get more
challenging for Oppenheimer because of
his past affiliations with left-leaning
political organizations coupled with his
opposition to the hydrogen bomb there
was increasing suspicions about his
loyalty and political alignment
these concerns came to a head in 1953
when oppenheimer's security clearance
was suspended this was under the
directive of President Eisenhower and a
special committee a hearing was held to
determine if oppenheimer's security
clearance would be reinstated the
hearings held in 1954 were a public
spectacle they pitted former colleagues
and Friends against each other and Drew
widespread attention
Oppenheimer was accused of having
communist ties and a threat to National
Security but these claims were never
proven
despite significant support from the
scientific Community the verdict of the
hearings was against him and his
security clearance was not reinstated
this decision effectively ended
oppenheimer's direct influence on
nuclear policy and it marked a dramatic
shift in his career and reputation
despite the earlier public humiliation
he remained a respected figure in the
scientific community
sadly oppenheimer's Health began to
deteriorate shortly after and in 1966 he
was diagnosed with throat cancer
[Music]
during his last weeks on Earth while
bedridden in 1967 Robert would reflect
on his life
while he was a professor back in the
1930s Robert's inability to focus made
him miss out on so much in the early
1930s he co-wrote a paper on What's
called the photoelectric effect it's a
description of how light rays can eject
electrons from Metals it's the very
mechanism that makes our solar panels
work today instead of realizing what an
amazing Discovery he had on his hands
Oppenheimer got bored and moved on to
another topic that he thought might be
more alluring meanwhile the graduate
student that he was working with kept
chipping up the problem he wasn't as
smart as Oppenheimer but he had more
discipline he tidied up the paper and
fixed some of the technical problems the
result a Noble Prize for that graduate
student
and the inpatient Oppenheimer missed out
but this was nothing compared to his
next blunder he and a colleague
discovered black holes by accident in
1939 strangely the paper was handed in
on the same day that Germany attacked
Poland
Oppenheimer and his colleague were
playing around with Einstein's
relativity equations and they noticed
something funny it predicted that if a
massive star burned through all of its
Fuel and collapsed on itself the
gravitational field it created would be
so intense that light itself couldn't
escape this was the discovery of the
black hole and it was the first academic
paper on the subject
so what did Oppenheimer do with this
well once again he forgot all about it
and moved on to something else which he
thought would be more interesting black
holes are very important in physics and
are increasingly relevant today if he
just stuck with his efforts who knows
what could have been this Behavior would
haunt Oppenheimer in the very last days
of his life
the saddest part of oppenheimer's life
wasn't the humiliation of the hearings
or even the detonation of the atomic
bombs
his friend who knew him best knew that
the real tragedy of his life was the
wasted potential they knew of
oppenheimer's frustrating Brilliance but
he just simply couldn't focus and see
things through
his friend knew that he got distracted
with the fame and the politics after the
Manhattan Project he had left his true
calling which was physics to them the
sorrow of oppenheimer's life was that he
never became the Einstein that he could
have been
heartbreakingly Oppenheimer knew this
when bedridden with cancer in 1967
oppenheimer's wife Kitty begged his
friend Freeman Dyson to visit him on his
deathbed she wanted them to do
scientific work together she said that
Oppenheimer had finally realized that
he'd squandered his potential he wanted
to give science one last go she was
hoping that Dyson could give his spirits
a boost
but Dyson declined he would later say
quote I agreed with Kitty about the
roots of his despair but I had to tell
her that it was too late I told her that
I would like to sit quietly with Robert
and hold his hand his days as a
scientist were over it was too late to
cure his anguish with equations
after a short battle with the disease
Oppenheimer would pass away on February
18 1967 at the age of 62.
thank you despite his passing the work
he began continued since the first
atomic bomb tests the world has seen a
proliferation of nuclear weapons
as of now nine countries openly
possessed nuclear weapons the United
States Russia the United Kingdom France
China India Pakistan Israel and North
Korea
despite numerous treaties and agreements
aimed at nuclear disarmament the world's
total number of nuclear warheads today
is estimated to be over thirteen
thousand most of these belong to the
United States and Russia making them the
most dominant nuclear powers on the
planet
unfortunately technological advancements
have increased the destructive potential
of these weapons
and for this reason the threat of
nuclear war remains a global concern
if there is another world war this
civilization may go under we need to ask
ourselves whether we're doing all we can
to avert that we need I think to learn
to understand
the realities of Life abroad
not so much in terms of slogans as in
terms of the lives of men
in our response to these realities there
is hope for peace
oppenheimer's story is a stark reminder
of the power that lies in human
knowledge and the care that we must take
in its application as Society continues
to push the boundaries of Science and
Technology we must take note of
oppenheimer's Journey and navigate our
own path with a mindful balance of
curiosity responsibility and a sense of
humanity
but there is another story here a story
in oppenheimer's personal life it's a
lesson to say if you're good at
something don't give up
and that is the story of Oppenheimer and
the Manhattan Project
if you want to see the cold fusion
episode of how one man stopped a nuclear
war in 1983 I'll leave a link to that in
the description below this individual is
largely forgotten today but if it wasn't
for him none of us would be here
okay so thanks for watching my name is
Togo and you have been watching cold
fusion and I'll catch you again soon for
the next episode cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
Fusion it's new thinking